Installing an operating system is very
similar to solving the problem of the
chicken and the egg. If you don't have
an operating system on the computer, how
are you supposed to install an operating
system? We commonly solve this problem
by booting our system to an installation
program that is usually running in a
barebones version of an operating
system. One common method is to use a
bootable USB drive. We've used
specialized software to make this USB
drive bootable, and we're using it on a
motherboard that is able to support
booting from a USB flash drive. We would
then put all of the installation
programs for the operating system on
this flash drive, install the flash
drive into a system, and start the
computer. But you may be in an
environment where you're either not able
to use those USB interfaces, or it may
be tedious to physically visit every
single computer just to install an
operating system. In that case, we might
want to boot the computer across the
network. This is a network boot that's
commonly referred to as Pixie or PXE.
This stands for preboot execution
environment. The BIOS of the computer
has to be able to support this Pixie
Boot functionality. And when you start
your computer, that pixie boot function
will look across your local network to
try to find a Pixie Boot server. Once it
finds that Pixie server, it can boot
that operating system installation
program as if it was a drive locally
connected to the computer. And of
course, you could use internal or
external solidstate drives or hard
drives to install these operating system
files and make those drives bootable so
that you can start the operating system
installation program when you start your
computer. Some systems can also boot and
install the operating system across the
internet. A good example of this is a
number of Linux distributions that are
designed with a minimal download to get
things started and then it downloads any
other code it might need from the
internet. Mac OS has a recovery
installation built into the BIOS of Mac
OS that will go out to the internet and
download versions of Mac OS to install.
And Windows Updates also provides a way
to install operating systems directly
from an internet source. Older operating
systems used to distribute their code on
optical discs, things like CDROMs and
DVD ROMs. There's a standard format for
taking an optical disc and taking
everything on that disc and creating a
disc image file known as an ISO image.
This ISO image contains everything that
would normally be found on that optical
disc. So, we can configure and set up an
entire OS installation on one single ISO
image and simply boot from that image.
This is a very common format to boot
from if you're using virtualization
software. And there are some external
drives that will mount that ISO image
and make the image appear as if it is a
physical disc. And since this is on an
external drive, you can disconnect it
from one computer, take it to another
computer, and perform another
installation. The same installation
files you have on the external or hot
swappable drive could also be copied to
an internal drive that's in your
computer. This means all of the
installation files would be available on
a local partition that's on your
computer and you simply boot from that
partition and install your operating
system into a separate partition on that
system. And it's not unusual for many
folks to install multiple operating
system types on the same computer. You
could have Windows and Linux on the same
physical device, for example, and then
decide which one to start during the
bootup process. This is often referred
to as a multioot system.
Once you start the installation process,
you also have a number of options on how
you would like to install those files
onto this system. One very common
approach is to perform a clean install.
This means we're going to wipe
everything in that partition and we're
going to completely reinstall the
operating system. When you're done with
a clean install, none of the previous
files that were on that system will
remain because you are deleting
everything and starting over from
scratch. If you already have a working
operating system on this computer and
you'd simply like to install a newer
version of the operating system and keep
all of your applications and all of your
data in place, then you'll want to
perform an in place upgrade. This means
you can update your operating system,
but you don't have to install any new
applications and you don't have to
recover any of your data files from
backup. In many organizations, this
process is streamlined by creating an
image deployment. This means you would
install an operating system on a
computer and then add the applications
and the configurations necessary to run
in your environment. Once you have this
exactly the way you would like it, you
can create an image of that system and
simply install the image on all of the
other computers. You can also completely
automate this process. So from the very
beginning to the very end of the reiming
process is something that doesn't
require any type of human intervention.
If you don't want to carry around an
external hard drive or bootable USB
drive to perform these installations,
you can put all of your install files on
a separate network drive, then you can
begin a remote network installation from
that local server or that local share
drive so that you don't have to have any
local media next to the computer. Most
modern operating systems will also
install a recovery partition. This is
commonly installed as a hidden
partition. So your enduser isn't
commonly going to see this partition,
but all of the installation files for
the operating system are contained in
that recovery partition. So if you're
doing any type of detailed
troubleshooting on a computer, but you
didn't bring any of the operating system
installation files, you'll probably be
able to find all of them in the recovery
partition. Windows also has a way to
reinstall the operating system by simply
copying over everything that's already
there, but leaving the base
configuration in place. This is referred
to as a repair installation, and it's
commonly done to fix any major problems
with the operating system that can't be
solved any other way. This will
overwrite all of your operating system
files, but it will leave all of your
user files and documents in place. And
in some cases, the drivers that are on
your installation program may not
recognize all of the hardware on your
computer. In that case, you may have to
load third-party drivers to connect to a
storage device or to a network
connection. You will usually have a
prompt during the installation process
itself that will ask you if you'd like
to install any of these third-party
drivers and then you have the
opportunity to install them and use that
hardware during the installation of the
program. You'll usually get a prompt
during the installation process itself
for installing these thirdparty drivers.
And once you install the drivers, you'll
now have access to the storage drive,
the network, or any other hardware
that's necessary to install this
operating
system. One of the challenges we're
often faced with in an organization is
that we may have users all over the
world. They have many different systems
that they might be using and we need to
have some way that they can perform this
operating installation but still be able
to have all of the configuration
settings necessary to use it on the
corporate network. Generally, we would
perform a zeroouch deployment to make
this happen. This is an automated
installation process that walks the user
through the installation with little or
no prompts that they would have to
answer. This would also include
configuration settings that are company
specific such as email server settings.
This means a user can open their new
laptop, turn it on, and then wait for
the installation process to complete.
And during that install, there will be
an automated script that will configure
the system, set up the domain
connections, configure the email
settings, and perform any other type of
configurations necessary for your
organization. Once you've built and
optimized one of these zero-ouch
deployments, you can reimage a laptop,
ship it to anywhere in the world to any
user in your organization, and they'll
be able to turn it on and immediately be
productive. Before we can install an
operating system, we need to create a
logical section of your storage drive
that will be designated as a place to
keep data. This is referred to as a disk
partition. Some operating systems prefer
having multiple partitions on a drive.
Others may use one single large
partition. And often you may want to set
up separate partitions just to keep data
separated on that storage device. We've
already discussed one type of partition
as a recovery partition and that's
something that the operating system
commonly creates during the installation
process itself. So once you're done and
you reboot the system, you may see the
operating system as one large partition.
But if you were to look closely at that
particular drive configuration, you
would see an additional hidden partition
for recovery. You might also want to
create separate partitions if you have
multiple operating systems that you're
installing. For example, you might take
part of the drive and dedicate it to a
Windows configuration and set up a
partition just for Windows and then
create a separate partition that you
would use for a Linux installation. Once
you create this partition and format the
partition with a particular file system,
Microsoft refers to these as volumes. If
you see this term being used in your
Windows documentation, just remember
that a volume is simply a formatted
partition. When you format a partition,
you'll be asked to format it with one of
two different styles. One of these
styles is a GPT partition style. This
stands for a GID partition table. that
GID is an abbreviation for globally
unique identifier. And if you're
installing one of the more recent
operating systems, you're probably
configuring the partition as a GPT
partition. To be able to use this GID
partition table style, you will need a
BIOS that is a UEFI BIOS. And this means
that you can configure up to 128
partitions using this GPT partition
style. If you have a storage drive big
enough, the GPT partition style will
support a total drive size of over 9
billion terabytes. Microsoft Windows,
though, has a limitation on the total
size of a GPT partition that is
currently set to 256 tab. If you're
familiar with the MBR partition style,
which we'll talk about in just a moment,
you'll know that that style uses a
method of partitioning known as extended
partitions and logical drives. Other
partition styles may require that you
configure the type of partition.
Fortunately, the GPT partition style
simply creates one of 128 partitions on
the drive, which makes it a much simpler
form of
partitioning. Before there was the GPT
partition style and before we had a UEFI
BIOS, we were using the MBR partition
style or master boot record. and you
will still find MBR partition styles
still in place and certainly you'll find
them on legacy devices. One of the
reasons that we no longer use the MBR
style is that the maximum partition size
that you can use with an MBR partition
is 2 terb. As you recall with the GPT
partition style, you could have 128
partitions on a storage drive and each
of those partitions was effectively the
same type of partition. With the MBR
partition style, you have two types of
partitions. There's a primary partition
and an extended partition. On an MBR
drive, a primary partition is the only
type of partition that is bootable. This
means if you're installing Windows,
Linux, or some other operating system on
your computer and you're using the MBR
partition style, you'll need to install
that operating system into one of those
bootable partitions. Keep in mind also
that you have a limited number of
primary partitions you can use. MBR only
supports four primary partitions per
storage drive. This means if you've
installed four separate bootable
operating systems into four of those
primary partitions, you've now maxed out
the primary partitions on your MBR
drive. Also, keep in mind that only one
of those partitions can be marked as the
active bootable partition on that drive.
If you want to automatically boot from a
different partition, you'll need to
change that in the partitioning software
of your
computer. But what if you wanted more
than four partitions on a single storage
drive? You can do that by installing one
extended partition on each storage
device. An extended partition is not
required, but it is something you can
install if you need additional
partitions on that drive. Inside of that
extended partition, you can then create
multiple logical partitions. Keep in
mind, however, that these logical
partitions are not bootable. So, if you
need a bootable partition, you would
need to configure one as a primary
partition. This partitioning process is
usually one of the very first things you
have to do when you're installing an
operating system. Sometimes there are
existing partitions on a drive and you
might need to remove them or you may be
able to add additional partitions along
with them. This is the dialogue box you
have inside of Windows when you want to
format a drive. And it's very similar to
the dialogue you get during an operating
system installation. You can see that
you can select which drive you would
like to use. And then you would decide
whether you would use MBR for master
boot record or GPT for the GID partition
table. Remember again that your MBR
style disc can only have up to four
primary partitions. And if you're using
a GID partition table, you can have up
to 128. This of course requires you to
have a UEFI BIOS or work in a BIOS
compatibility mode which was a common
mode when we were transitioning from our
older style BIOS to the newer UEFI BIOS.
If you enable the BIOS compatibility
mode, it disables the ability to secure
boot, which means that many of your
newer operating systems will not work in
a BIOS compatibility mode. This process
of creating a partition or removing a
partition can very easily delete your
data. You have to know exactly what
partition you would like to remove and
what is on that particular partition. So
if you're doing any type of drive
administration on your local computer,
make sure you're very careful not to
repartition or change your existing
partitions because you could very easily
lose
data. This is the installation screen
you get at the very beginning of the
Windows installation so that you can
partition an area for Windows to be
installed. The installation for this
computer has found a 60 gig drive and
it's showing that there is nothing
allocated in that 60 gig. This means
that there are no existing partitions
that we might need to delete or work
around. And you'll notice that we have
options here to add new partitions. We
can install additional device drivers
from this screen. So if we have a
separate drive controller that we've
installed, we can install the device
driver directly from the screen. And of
course, we can select that drive and
then decide how big of a partition we
might need for the Windows
installation. Once we've created a
partition that we would use to install
the operating system, we first need to
format that partition to be able to
store data in it. And there are two ways
to do this in Windows. There's the quick
format and there's the full format. The
quick format, as the name implies, is a
very quick way to perform a format
because all it's really doing is
creating a file table on that partition.
It's not performing any physical checks
of the storage drive either. So, you
would want to feel comfortable that that
drive was safe to store data on. This
quick format is effectively erasing the
file system table as if no data was ever
installed on that particular drive. From
a security perspective, this technically
means that we could recover some of that
old data with the right software. So, if
you want a secure installation, a quick
format may not be the best choice. If
you're installing Windows 10 or Windows
11, quick format is the default setting
during that installation. If you wanted
to perform a full format, you could
change that in the disk part utility. A
full format is a much more intensive
formatting process. it's going to write
zeros across the entire disc which means
it effectively erases anything that was
there previously. One of the drawbacks
to this of course is that it has to go
through the entire drive to write this
information and that can be
timeconuming. So if you need this
installation to be done very quickly you
might want to choose quick format but if
this is something that needs to be much
more secure a full format might be your
better option.